il est l'un des tournois challengers les
plus prisées du circuit atp le
classement mondial de tennis depuis 14
ans les meilleurs joueurs du top 100 des
jeunes talents étrangers et des français
comme nicolas mahut ou encore michaël
llodra s'y sont illustrés
stéphane robert licencié à blois yamaner
que journaliste en 2009 alors aucun
joueur régional n'était allé plus loin
que les huitièmes de finale dans ce
tournoi alors ce tournoi il apprécie
tout particulièrement
j'ai toujours fait le maximum pour venir
ici maintenant il ya des moments où
j'étais j'ai joué un petit peu les
catégories au dessus donc et parfois
voilà j'ai pas joué pendant quelques
années je suis pas venu mais j'ai été ça
a été un tremplin aussi en 2009 quand
j'ai joué la finale
c'était la première fois je battais un
joueur aussi fort j'ai battu jérémy
chardy gtel en finale première fois que
j'allais en finale sur un aussi gros
tournois donc c'est une très très belle
épreuve
l'homme qui porte l'open d'orléans à
bout de bras depuis le début ces nuits
lidié gérard pendant l'événement il ne
va pas s'arrêter une seule seconde
difficile même de le suivre mais son
travail ne se résout pas seulement
capitonné ses cinquante et une semaine
par an de préparation
et donc on a on doit préparer bien sûr
les réservations avec les partenaires
les rencontrer j'en ai 160 les chefs
d'entreprise ils n'ont pas à ma
disposition
quand je vous dis qu'ils aient le temps
de me recevoir et après il ya toute
l'organisation l'hôtel l'hôtellerie la
restauration des joueurs de
l'organisation est bien sûr dvi p cette
année on a fait plus de trois mille cinq
cents couverts aux côtés de didier
gérard il y à l'ancien joueur
professionnel nicolas discuter son rôle
être ambassadeur le rôle d'ambassadeurs
et de vallées assister un petit peu
d'aidé gérard directeur du tournoi sur
toute la partie harper au prêt va
justement des des partenaires c'est
aller à leur rencontre
que ce soit pour les cocktails qui sont
organisées les déjeuners ou des dîners
d'échangés de
de partage et de
leur exposer un petit peu comment le
tournoi fonctionne comment il supporte
comment il se comporte
comment il peut être reconnu que ce soit
au niveau national ou international donc
donc c'est surtout ça moi mon rôle mon
rôle ici auprès de auprès de l'open
d'orléans des partenaires justement il
faudra en trouver encore plus dès 2019
puisque le tournoi devra accueillir
encore plus de joueurs